oh I know what mine is like you know
right after you puke when you're drunk
and you get like residual or bio spicy
how caballo like spicy yeah that's what
this is yeah but it's healthy for you
someone
do we shoot it yeah oh how well how is a
birthday still up in my mother
I'm just gonna shoot it tastes like
Martinelli it wasn't that bad if his
amazing he's at the bottom of mine so
you got the fungus in this one am I
gonna trip and then get a trip no you
didn't eat it all right let's do it
oh no uh wow this smells rich this is
like alien guys this is I go bump I love
it textures horrible detects your spawn
is worth more this reminds me of the
medicines that have a nostril that
usually isn't something that people like
the taste
well it is the great medicine it was
really good it's super fun imagine doing
that with some bees look back pardon
yeah I can I get uh okay I would have
committed I come
yeah
that got campus well ours looks like
Gatorade and Kelsey's looks like pond
water yeah right Oh Stace fantastic no
somebody pay fine and tell me it tastes
like y'all's whoa Mike but it looks like
somebody bottled a puddle
it's like healthy solar like how he
showed up it's like healthy summer that
you could work yes it's like healthy
soda than you do
toasts do you have a seizure oh my god